Kim K goes altra glam for her latest of  photo shoot the star shared some behind  the scenes that snaps from her mystery  shoe to showing off her curves in space  yes she was rocking a major mermaid  extensions her pal  Lala even dropped by look at this diva  coming to my photo shoot sitting in glam  getting her hair and makeup done for  hours while I'm gonna set the shoot  might be for Kim's app where she  recently unearthed her 1994 middle  school graduation tape  look at baby Kim never forget though et  dug up the tape at first finding this  iconic moment my name is Kim Kardashian  I'm the dopest on the Rufus person in  the class the things I said I have no  idea I just want to know where they got  that video because I think it's funny do  you think you knew back then it seems  like you knew now existed for fame I  don't know what I was saying I don't  know